جماعات الدينيه لو تعطينا فكره عن وجودها
داخل الاروقه السياسيه التركيه هل هي
ملحوظه هل هي ما زالت قادره على توصيل
افكارها ولها نفوذ
بالله
في السياقه التركيه والجماعات الدينيه في
الحقيقه
حكم الحزب العداله والتنميه التركيب والذي
يتولى السلطه 2002
الى الجماعه الدينيه المختلفه والسعه
النفوذ ضمن المجتمع التركي وكذلك ضمن
القضائي والجيش
تركيا وهذا يعود ايمن اللي هي حقيقه ان
حزب العداله ولا تنميا هو في الحقيقه
دخل في علاقه مصالحه مشتركه مع هذه
الجماعات فالحزب يجندوا المرشحين
السياسيين ويحصل على الدعم الكبير لما
ضماته في المحاضرات مختلفه
وحتى الموظفون ياتون من هذه الجماعات
الدينيه ويقدمون تبرعات كثيره
العداله والتنميه هو الحزب الوحيد
المستفيد عمليا من سياسه الربح المتبادل
مع هذه الجمعيات امن هناك اطراف اخرى داخل
تركيا
نومي نوكوش
استفادت من هذه الجماعات الدينيه ولكن
باتجالين بان حزب العداله والتنميه هو
المستفيده الرئيسي لانه الحزب الذي يتولى
السلطه وهو الذي يسيطر على الموارد العامه
و لهذا السبب في العديد من الجماعات
الدينيه او من مصلحتها ان تدعم الحزب
الحاكم
الذي يحصل في اعلى مستويات في تركيا
الى القوى السياسيه